que pierre henry ancien directeur
général de france terre d'asile et
président de france fraternité
pierre-henri bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors ce
nouveau pacte a donc notamment a pour
objectif de remplacer le controversé
règlement dublin mais aussi de rendre
obligatoire la solidarité de tous les
membres de l'union européenne face à une
arrivée massive de migrants dans les
pays concernés
est-ce que vous saluer ce pacte ce soir
mais d'abord nous n'en sommes pas à
l'élaboration et à l'adoption du pacte
qui a été présentée aujourd'hui c'est
une note d'intention de la commission
européenne ensuite il va y avoir un
processus législatif c'est complexe avec
des allers retours entre le parlement
européen et le conseil des états membres
donc nous sommes loin de la coupe aux
lèvres et la note d'intention assez
fournie qui a été élaboré aujourd'hui
par la commission européenne
en réalité puis du neuf avec du vieux
je m'explique au moment de la crise
migratoire de thomis 15
la commission européenne avait sorti
toute une série de mesures assez
coercitive et qui d'ailleurs n'avait pas
véritablement a été mise en place et
donc aujourd'hui on assiste à ce
recyclage
je vous rappelle que la semaine dernière
la présidente de la commission
européenne c'est la fin d'un règne âme
disait que l'union allait abandonner une
système de dublin
en réalité il n'en est rien et à la
place ou plus exactement avec le
maintien du système de tubes rock c'est
une véritable usine à gaz qui est mise
en place
né dont il y à fort à parier que
beaucoup de mesures ne verront pas le
jour
ou alors seront parfaitement inefficaces
les vous en citer une l'union la
commission prévoit de mettre un certain
nombre de hotspots c'est-à-dire de lieux
de rétention frontières intérieures de
l'union et aux frontières extérieures
notamment pour les personnes demandeuses
d'asile dont la nationalité à un taux de
reconnaissance inférieur à 20 % dans
l'union européenne
autrement dit on va multiplier les
situations analogues à celles du camp de
maria sont sans souci si genève tient en
rien des ong on le voyait notamment dans
le sujet le dénonce ce pacte s'il est
adopté cette grève pour aux pays les
plus hostiles à l'accueil des réfugiés
comme la pologne la hongrie la
république tchèque ou la slovaquie est
ce que c'est le cas quel est votre avis
ah bah il est clair quand que quand le
chancelier autrichien sébastien kurtz ou
victor bad france des sourcils
la commission elle reste de l'union
quand même tendance à se mettre au
garde-à-vous en tout cas à faire ou
alors sinon à faire des grandes
déclarations mais qui sont pas suivies
d'effets les 27 pays de l'union c'est
une communauté de valeurs c'est une
communauté de destin et tant que l'on ne
sanctionnera pas un certain nombre de
pays européens qui ne respectent pas la
règle commune bien chacun continuera à
faire ce qu'il veut et bitter bars et
les pays depuis ce grade et bien
continuerons à dire que lille navale
accueillir
personne et sans aucune sanction ne sais
moi je suis profondément européen mais
je suis pour une majorité de projets je
crois que quand on n'arrive pas à
avancer à 27
il faut le faire avec les principaux
pays notamment sur cette question
migratoire
d'accueil c'est à dire à 8,9 et puis
éventuellement d'autres pays qui
viennent s'y joindre aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une efficacité globale
l'union européenne
il ya quand même du mal à exister aux
frontières le sujet est extrêmement
compliqué il ne faut pas le simplifier
c'est complexe mais ce que je pense
profondément c'est qu'il y à un corpus
de droit que l'union européenne doit
respecter et l'externalisation de nos
problèmes sur les pays tiers n'est pas
une option acceptable
autre élément il faut absolument que
l'union européenne si elle veut s'en
sortir est bien investi dedans pour
parvenir à une réelle harmonisation des
systèmes d'accueil et procédures d'asile
tout au travers de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui c'est la division la plus
totale et je pense que l'union ne peut
pas se décharger de ses responsabilités
sur les pays tiers alors ce pacte
propose aussi peut-être pour conclure à
mettre à l'abri des poursuites
judiciaires les ong qui sauve des
migrants en mer on en parle souvent
alors elles seront à l'abri mais est ce
que cela sous-entend que rien ne
changera finalement pas dû coûter
oui c'est le moins qu'on puisse faire
sauver des vies en méditerranée c'est
dans l'adn
de l'union de l'humanité et c'est bien
normal que les ong soient exclus de
toute poursuite mais la vraie question
c'est que fait-on véritablement par
exemple en méditerranée centrale au
niveau institutionnel pour sauver des
vies il ya des centaines des centaines
des milliers de personnes qui se noie
dans la méditerranée et comme l'union
européenne à retirer ses forces de
sauvetage de et de surveillance en
méditerranée
il reste plus souvent sur sommes que des
bateaux privés
donc je crois vraiment que cette
question va nous occuper encore quelques
quelques temps et que pour l'instant je
le disais en introduction de cet
entretien nous ne sommes qu'au début
d'une note d'intention qui vous irez
subira beaucoup de transformations
pichot rappelle accessoirement que la
présidence de l'union européenne sera
assumée en 2021 par le portugal et la
slovénie et puis au moment de l'élection
présidentielle de tobique 22 par la
france et donc il y à fort à parier que
nous n'aboutirons pas sur toute une
série de tests avant juillet 2022
merci beaucoup pillant et d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes ancien directeur général de
france terre d'asile et président de
france fraternité